The Joe Rogan experience.
My God, I mean it's,
it's a mystery enough to be
born a human being a tool.
Yes. You know, just to be
alive is a, is, is, is,
is an extraordinary mystery,
yes.
To have the ability to love, uh, to, to,
to feel emotions, um, to
understand beauty, to be moved by,
by, by a symphony. All of all of
these things we take for granted,
but actually they're deeply mysterious.
We don't really know what we are or,
or who we are.
And which is one of the reasons I'm so
fascinated by Rick Strassman's work.
Are you, you presented his
film, Dmt, the spirit molecule,
and on my upcoming speaking to her, I'm
going to be doing an event with Rick, uh,
on the 14th or 15th of May in Sedona.
I think it will be the first time that
Rick has spoken publicly for quite a
while. Rick has a colleague
called Andrew Gallimore, uh,
who teaches at the University
of Aachen hour, uh, in Japan.
And Rick and Andrew have together
developed a, uh, technology, uh,
for releasing DMT into human volunteers
in a very slow drip that will keep them
in the DMT state if they
wish for hours on end.
And,
and the intention,
the intention is to use this technology
to explore and map the DMT realm.
When do I sign up? Soon as possible.
It's very close. Imperial College,
it looks like Imperial College London
is going to deploy this technology in
further research into DMT and that that
research is not going to be purely and
simply into the therapeutic
potential of a psychedelic,
which is very important research to do.
It's going to be an investigation into
the nature of reality using a psychedelic,
the mysterious nature of reality.
And it is art.
And you know this from personal experience
that when you get plunged into that
DMT realm,
it is so different from the realm
of our daily daily world filled,
filled with geometry,
filled with these sprightly intelligences
completely internally coherent.
How can that be, you know,
generated by the brain, or are,
are we dealing with some other level of
reality that we haven't encountered yet?
I think that ancient cultures,
and in particular my lost civilization,
were deeply involved in exploring
the mysterious nature of reality.